[Applause]
Oh, I
've tried our party's far-reaching Korean People's Army Palace. What's the party Levi's
resonance like? I'll give you a
shattering one-protein government
[Applause]
Our regimes are important and they don't
even know  Now, in the darkness and
guts, we are renting a new product that will take better care of the shim and the station name
[Applause]
Oh, noona's reliable nothing tree
is the first of our daily crew that the whole country is proud of
.
Fly now  Coming solo reagent is
proceeding with the bamak tip
Oh,
our revolution, who is regretting the high and various breaking moves, is betting on the nerds the audience is a
little bit of a jerk
[Applause]
Just less dog-like  The result of soybean oil that will become a dagger will be
every mouthful
[Applause]